I love the song after I talk to a girl
at the high school and I'm really
because look she was very memorable to
me because in high school we were the
last two virgins that you and I remember
when I found that out I called her and
pitched her why we should be each
other's first in my whole pitch was this
we went to we went to preschool together
I've known you forever we're gonna do
something embarrassing but why not do
that in front of each other I can't
embarrass myself part of you you can't
embarrass yourself in front of me
we should be jealous and she was like
you know what that's a good idea
we're gonna be each other's first and so
this song is how that night way you're
catching on like a bit the song is it we
[ __ ] before over 30 times like that
[Laughter]
first thing you'd be mine we'd be
together to the end of time I laid her
down and I kissed her lips jeans on
jeans and hit some nice things were
going just as we planned she was my girl
yeah hello I went believe me she's told
you we all get up in my room they passed
out first that's a rookie move
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
put just a little from the side ready
just pretend like you've heard it before
I'm gonna go right through you know the
big black because that's what distracted
me last night she said this mood just
right my finger just right
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]